no Ted let's come back to your first
directing job you know believe you said
that your first directing job was was
all or nothing if it didn't go well you
would have been out of a job and on the
street and you could have played it safe
you could have you could have declined
the directing job or the directing
assignment but you decided to risk it
all so knowing what was that stake how
did you approach the work well what
happened was that I was theater and when
when I was 23 I was a story editor of
the series
General Motors theater and the man who
produced it Sydney Newman he said to me
one day you know Ted I was doing a lot
of rewriting it was a great training
because people drugs illusion I'm 10
minutes sharp I need two scenes right
I'd write two scenes and and then but
after about a year of this the producer
was sitting you in Kevin said to me you
know Ted you're a pretty good writer not
a great writer but a pretty good writer
but I know but I know one thing you
really would be a good great ad and I
said what's that he said you'd be a
great director now why'd you say this I
never asked him why he said this he said
here's what I'm gonna do
I'd like you to do you're gonna do one
show for me live television drama if I
like it I'll give you a year's contract
if I don't like it
you're out in the street you can't come
back to this job I said I'll risk it he
said if you don't want to risk it you
can stay on you're doing a great job as
a story editor and I said no no I want
to be a director I'll risk it
and so he allowed me to direct and of
course I worked my butt off getting it
every shot because it had to go live
there was nothing like it I said a funny
story about directing life on the series
the theme music was Charlie Chaplin's
smile smile la da da dadad a smile when
your heart is breaking that was our
theme music right of course as just
before the musical on the assistants a
10-9 and my stomach starter knee is
going all across Canada seven
and you're ready ready 8-bit music ready
I'm camera to hit these fade up on
camera - super the titles gillip you
forgot say captor 3 go on move a little
closer a little closer please take one
and it's what you were conducting old
show non-stop right and your stomach's
going in that vente leads up to here
dissolve 20 years later I'm in a lovely
dining room a restaurant rather with a
lovely woman and we're drinking wine and
it's very romantic and my stomach starts
to trend stop it and ghost keeps
churning what do I hear over the
loudspeakers the restaurant smile when
your heart is breaking
to this day I'm like Pavlov's dog here
that he's accepted sure they did it for
two years anyway he allowed me to direct
and he was a great a greatest mentor for
me
and I think every person who wants to
start out being director you need
someone to mentor you and but what made
you take that leap you know knowing that
you could be out of a job knowing that
you could lose the the safety and the
security you still decided you know what
I want to do this what where did that
come from
well I wanted to be a director and here
I was being given a chance to be a
director how many offers will you get of
that kind in your whole life so it's
just I'll let you direct so I rely just
had to grab I'm not interested in a job
I was interested in being a director so
you had to take it it was an opportunity
it was being offered to you it would be
silly to refuse it and and then and then
knowing that if it doesn't go and go
well that you know you could you could
you could be out on the street I mean so
just just coming back to the approach
that what you said you worked your butt
off but would tell us about the work you
put in well at first I started as a
stagehand and then I worked as a floor
manager so I'm the assistant director
and and I used to call myself the
translator I have I work for two very
fiery to represent tell that stupid
three feet to a damn left
darling
take three sleeps to your left I was
always translating what looks getting in
my ear I was on the floor working
with the crew and the actress and I did
that and then finally I got this Chan
when I went Sydney one was a big a very
very important documentary filmmaker for
the National Film Board and so they
brought him over to do to do
documentaries on television and I when I
heard that that he was going to do
documentaries about new thoughts and new
discoveries at the University of Toronto
I went to him I said hey I just graduate
I want to speak to him I said I'm just
graduated from U of T in physics and in
English that literature absolutely and
he was kind of amused by me and he said
okay you can I run it I like to write
ten or twelve documentaries and of
course I wrote them and he rewrote the
minutes and he taught me so much about
writing for documentaries like he's a 10
look look the picture does one thing the
writings can't do the same thing
otherwise there's duplicate and
redundant you want to have the pictures
say one thing and then the words say
something else so you have two things
for the price of one always so he taught
me a lot about writing for documentaries
and of course he rewrote and rewrote
everything I wrote and then of course
the only can happen in a big
bureaucratic organization like the CBC
they take this guy who's great at
documentaries and it they didn't have a
head of drama department for six months
it was empty so they said they wanted
him to eat the head of the German fire
now he was a bit insecure about English
literature etc and I was a graduate of
English the jury said Tim Ted would you
like to come with me in that I had to
trust your taste and judgment in drama
and that's how I got to be the job that
job and then as I say then from then I
got the job as being it it gave me an
opportunity to become a director
you